Ja. Willkommen zu einer neuen Sendung
von Philocast. Ich freue mich sehr,
den Bitcoin Experten Marcel Ohrenschall hier
im Studio zu haben im Gespräch. Hallo Marcel,
ich freue mich sehr, dass du dich bereiterklärt
hast, heute ein bisschen zur Verfügung zu stehen.
Und zwar geht es heute um die Philosophie
von Bitcoin. Bitcoin ist in aller Munde,
aber ich glaube, die allerwenigsten wissen,
was darunter genau zu verstehen ist.
Mal sinkt der Kurs, mal steigt er. Gerade ist
eher so ein bisschen im Sinken, aber es ist nur
eine Frage der Zeit, bis er wieder steigt.
Darüber werden heute auch sprechen. Manuel,
kannst du mal für unsere Zuschauerinnen
und Zuschauer kurz und knackig erklären,
was ist eigentlich Bitcoin?
Was hat es damit auf sich?
Ja Hallo Jörg, danke für die Einladung. Ich
bin froh, dass wir das Video machen. Ich
habe das Gefühl, bei Bitcoin fehlt
die philosophische Ebene manchmal,
wenn darüber gesprochen wird. In der Szene selbst
ist Philosophie auch ein wesentlicher Bestandteil
der Auseinandersetzung. Deswegen freue ich mich
drauf. Genau die Frage Was ist Bitcoin? Ist,
glaube ich einer der einfachsten
und zugleich schwierigsten Fragen.
Und vorweg methodologisch für alle Zuschauer und
Zuschauerinnen will so motivierend ankündigen.
Ich glaube, meine Erklärung wird jetzt
nicht den Schalter umlegen bei den meisten,
sondern es ist ein interaktiver Prozess. Die
Leute müssen immer wieder sich damit beschäftigen,
um zu verstehen, was es ist. So ging es
mir, so geht es eigentlich allen. Man hört
es zum 1. Mal irgendwann 2017 schaut sich das
zwei Jahre lang an, dann vergisst man es und
taucht wieder ein und fängt alles, alles von
vorne an und ich glaube, das ist superwichtig.
Zu so im Hinterkopf zu behalten, warum ein
Bitcoin eine extrem komplexe Sache ist. Also
es ist sozusagen klassischerweise wird es als
digitales Gold oder digitales Geld gesehen,
also als digitale Kryptowährung.
Das ist ja auch die Bezeichnung,
die oft verwendet wird. Dafür gibt
es technische Gründe dahinter,
also wie es Bitcoin ist. Dieses digitale Geld
designed und und und und und programmiert.
Und da ist zum Beispiel Kryptographie
ein wesentlicher Bestandteil und
deswegen heißt es halt Kryptowährung.
Also Kryptographie. Kurz gesagt ist die Kunst auch
zu verschlüsseln. Die Verschlüsselung ist Kunst,
die verbergen Kunst von Griechisch, Krypto also
die Krypta gibt es ja auch, also es hat was mit
kryptisch, so kennen wir das. Das Verborgenes
hat also immer so ein bisschen auch was leicht
Mystisches oder Dunkles, um sich herum. Und
wann wurde ungefähr Bitcoin so erfunden?
Kann man das so sagen? Seit
wann gibt es das Phänomen?
Ja, also seit 2009. Kann man sagen, der
erste, also Bitcoin, hat ja eine Datenbank,
in der alle Transaktionen gespeichert sind, und
diese Datenbank ist dezentral. Das bedeutet,
die ist überall auf der Welt auf tausenden
Millionen von Computern gespeichert, gänzlich.
Und da kann man eben einsehen, dass der erste
Block 2009 entstanden ist mit der 1. Transaktion,
der sogenannte Genesis Block, dass die Entstehung
von Bitcoin gewesen, und da hat es auch diesen
mythischen Charakter auf einmal bekommen,
weil die Person, die Bitcoin erfunden hat,
ist das Pseudonym Satoshi Nakamoto ist bis
heute unbekannt, wer dieses Pseudonym ist.
Also man weiß nicht mal, ob es eine Person
war oder nicht mehrere. Und das hat natürlich
fast schon. Also deswegen kann ich verstehen,
dass es auch in der Szene so quasi religiöse
Anhänger gibt. Die, die das Ganze zum
Himmel loben. Also nur zum Himmel loben,
ohne Kritik. Ich glaube, es hat viele Vorteile,
aber man sollte auch kritisch draufgucken.
Und genau seit 2009 gibt es das. Der Grund dafür
war die Wirtschaftskrise. Also das ist die weit
verbreitete Theorie, dass sozusagen mit dem mit
dem Platzen der Immobilienblase in den USA der
erste Bitcoin Mining Block dann sozusagen die
Chance gesehen hat. Und dann war so okay jetzt,
jetzt starten wir das Projekt, das Experiment,
diesen Versuch eine neue digitale Währung in
die Welt zu setzen, weil es gab davor eben auch
schon andere Währungen wie ich, hash oder digital.
Es waren andere Versuche, Versuche oder Hash. Cash
gibt es auch, ja, und und und das ist eben, dass
es eben so ein bisschen die Entstehungsgeschichte
Satoshi Nakamoto war aktiv online, der hat dieses
Bitcoin in seiner Email Liste an alle möglichen
Leute geschickt, die mit Kryptographie was zu tun
hatten. Und wurde von vielen auch belächelt.
Und das habe ich heute auch noch mal gesehen.
Das kann ich einblenden in einem Link, dass
sozusagen die Technologie für Bitcoin gar nicht
die beste oder neueste war oder ist bis heute,
dass Satoshi Nakamoto hat sich von älteren,
schon Jahrzehnte alten technologischen Funktionen
bedient in der digitalen Kryptographie und hat
bloß eine interessante, bisher unentdeckte
Kombination aus allem hergestellt und damit,
was so semi Neues erfunden. Und das ist Bitcoin.
Okay, das ist ja interessant, der Zug der
digitalen Technologie. Man kann immer wieder
zurückgreifen auf vorhandene Technologie, gehen
und kann daraus was Neues machen. Interessant
auch finde ich, dass der Gründer oder die
Gründerin wir wissen es ja nicht oder die
Gründer, dass die selbst auch verborgen
sind. Also der Name ist Programm. Also
Anonymität spielt im Internet, im Zeitalter
der Digitalität eine ganz besondere Rolle.
Anonymität muss nicht was Schlechtes sein, oder
Pseudonyme, muss man genauer sagen. Man hat
sich einen Namen gegeben, nur vielleicht
nicht der Klarname, der richtige Name,
die wird als eine Art von Lebensform sichtbar, in
dem Raum der Digitalität. Also das finde ich auch
aus diesem Gesichtspunkt sehr, sehr spannend. Ja,
das hast du schon gesagt. Es gibt polarisierende
Wirkung von Bitcoin, die einen finden es ganz
toll, die anderen finden es ganz schlecht.
Und das führt uns jetzt, glaube ich, mitten
hinein in die philosophische Diskussion,
die wir heute anstreben. Wollen. Vielleicht fragen
wir mal diese Frage Sollte Geld die Möglichkeit zu
Anonymität gewährleisten? Also wie sieht es aus
mit Anonymität? Traditionellerweise ist ja Geld
ja immer auch schon ein bisschen anonym gewesen.
Man hat Geld vielleicht auf dem Bankkonto, man
hat Geld im Portemonnaie, aber das Geld hat ja die
Besonderheit, dass es eine virtuelle Realität ist.
Geld ist ja nicht direkt an den materiellen
Träger gebunden, wie es jetzt andere Werte sind,
sondern Geld kann auf dem Papier Stück
stehen, wenn wir uns darüber einig sind,
dass das diesen Wert hat. Und Bitcoin denkt
diesen Gedanken ja so ein bisschen noch weiter,
weil da ja gar kein Papier Schein mehr ist.
Also wie würdest du dieses Verhältnis von
Anonymität und Bitcoin philosophisch beschreiben?
Was ist der Vorteil davon?
Ja, also ich mags halt immer gern bei
Problemen vielleicht auch anzufangen.
Also genau bei Bitcoin ist es eben so die
Frage, welche Probleme gehen damit einher,
dass zum Beispiel wenn man sich vorstellt, dass
alles transparent ist. Und es ist nun mal so, dass
man vielleicht einfach philosophisch und ethisch
das recht haben sollte, also normativ gesagt,
das recht haben sollte, auch zur Privatsphäre,
wie der Datenschutz in Deutschland extrem streng
ist und den den Nutzer des Internets zu schützen
versucht, ist es eben beim Geld irgendwie anders.
Scheinbar in der in Deutschland oder auch
in Europa. Da ist eine Tendenz da, sozusagen
möglichst transparent die Geldflüsse einzusehen,
immer mit der Behauptung mit so zum Schutz
Vorgabe, also mit so einer Sorge Argumentation des
Staates, dass man sagt, man möchte eben kriminelle
Geldflüsse irgendwie besser in Griff bekommen.
Und ja, jetzt neigen halt viele dazu zu sagen,
bei Bitcoin ist es so, dass das durch diese
Pseudonyme oder Anonymität Kriminelle irgendwie
so ein Planschbecken haben, indem sie jetzt
noch mehr Böses machen können und und und.
Es zeigt sich aber, dass sozusagen die, die
also Bitcoin war bisher eine gute Option
für kriminelle Aktivitäten, weil die Leute keine
Ahnung von der Technologie hatten, nicht wussten,
wie man diese Blockchain durch scannt und so aber
von den Qualitäten der Blockchain. Und so wie das
Ganze gehandhabt ist, ist Bitcoin äußerst
transparent. Die Blockchain, also die, die
diese Datenbank, in der alle Transaktionen
gespeichert sind, ist von jedem einsehbar.
Das heißt, mittlerweile gibt es auch Tools
und das wurde auch vom amerikanischen Senat
oder Gericht. Ich bin mir gerade unsicher und da
kann ich auch noch mal eine Quelle hinzufügen,
wurde in den USA eben bewiesen, dass man
von kriminellen Geldflüssen, wenn man weiß,
wofür das Geld verwendet wurde, angenommen von
Drogendealern Höhe von 1,5 Milliarden €? Ich weiß
es nicht. Dann, dann, dann kann man eben selbst
mit mit sämtlichen Methoden, die die Kriminellen
so zur Verfügung haben, um Geldwäsche zu
betreiben, Rückschlüsse daraus ziehen.
Aus dieser Transparenz Qualität der Bitcoin
Blockchain, wer dahinter steckt. Es ist also
total dumm, als Krimineller mittlerweile Bitcoin
zu verwenden oder zumindest sehr risikoreich. Und
da haben wir halt noch mal zurück zum Bargeld, zum
normalen Euro. Da ist Bargeld halt viel besser.
Um anonym zu bleiben und sozusagen ich würde
behaupten, die die Forderung nach Transparenz ist
sozusagen gleich geblieben, dass wir von Euro zu
Bitcoin wechselt, ändert an dieser Sache nichts.
Jetzt die Frage so okay, ist Anonymität
gut oder schlecht? Und ich glaube,
es hat halt eben einen ideellen Wert, dass
man seine Privatsphäre schützen kann. So
wie beim Online surfen man seine Daten
nicht, dass die nicht verkauft werden
sollten. Durch große Firmen wie Facebook
und und und. Google oder Amazon ist es auch,
finde ich beim Geld total wichtig, dass
wir die Option zur Anonymität haben.
Und die Option zur Transparenz. Also eben so
eine Art Freiheit in dem Geldsystem, dass man
entscheiden kann, wann man das zeigen möchte
oder nicht, wäre glaube ich äußerst sinnvoll.
Und bei Bitcoin hat man halt tendenziell eher die
Freiheit dazu, weil es Pseudonymen ist. Das heißt,
es ist einerseits transparent und wenn man darauf
achtet, kann man praktisch auch anonym bleiben.
Gut, also es zeigt, Bitcoin macht die
Sache noch viel flexibler. Bitcoin
ist das moderne Geld vielleicht, die das Geld
der Zukunft Du hast schon Blockchain erwähnt,
eine Datenbank, in der alles gesichert wird,
alles koordiniert wird. Blockchain ist ja auch
ein Riesenthema. Darüber könnte man auch
mal eine eigene Sendung machen. Jetzt habe
ich noch eine Frage. Du hast jetzt sehr die
positiven Dinge hervorgehoben von Bitcoin.
Jetzt könnte man auch sagen, dieser Energieaufwand
der dazu da nötig ist, um Bitcoins zu erzeugen,
die müssen ja auch häufig gemeint werden. Das
könntest du auch noch ein bisschen erzählen. Den
Prozess, wie Bitcoins überhaupt zustande kommen.
Erzeugt das nicht sehr viel Umweltverschmutzung,
also viel Energiebedarf, auch in der
heutigen Zeit, wo wir nicht mehr so
viel Energie vielleicht haben, oder spart
man damit vielleicht Energie, weil man sagt,
man muss das Geld nicht mehr pressen in Münzen,
man muss es nicht mehr drucken auf Geldscheine.
Das ist ja alles nur noch virtuell,
nicht mehr physisch. Also erste Frage
Wie wird es produziert? Und zweite
Frage Wie ist die Klimabilanz?
Ja, also das ist mein Lieblingsthema, gerade
weil es einfach unglaublich vielseitig ist und
gerade so viel Erkenntnis und Forschung ans Licht
kommt bei dem ganzen Thema. Ich möchte die Antwort
in drei Teilen beantworten, weil die Frage zu
beantworten, weil sozusagen zu allererst die
methodische Frage so ab wann ist denn etwas
ein also Energieverschwendung? Ich glaube,
da würde ich auch mit dir gerne vielleicht mit
deinem Feedback drüber reden, weil Fakt ist,
Bitcoin braucht Energie, wir können später
reden wie viel und so, aber es braucht Energie.
Und jetzt wird dieses Statement gebracht.
Naja, es verbraucht aber Energie. Also es
braucht nicht nur, es verbraucht, es ist
eine Verschwendung. Und da frage ich mich
okay ab wann ist ein Energie Gebrauch ein
Verbrauch bzw eine Verschwendung. Und ich
glaube das kann man da wäre die Prämisse zu
sagen, worauf sich alle einig sind. Wenn man
das überhaupt nicht dann etwas gar keinen
Nutzen hat, dann ist es eine Verschwendung.
Beispiel Ich gehe abends raus, spazieren und meine
gesamte Wohnung leuchtet das Licht, obwohl ich es
nicht brauche. So, ich kann verstehen, dass
sozusagen von außen viele Menschen, die Bitcoin
noch nicht in dein System eingetaucht sind und
auch kein Nutzen darin sehen, intuitiv erst mal
sagen es ist eine komplette Verschwendung.
So, das ist so glaube ich der erste Punkt.
Und dann ist es so, dass es wir beide genau
im zweiten Schritt eigentlich sagen Ja, okay,
wenn wir uns jetzt aber einigen, irgendwie Bitcoin
hat einen ganz klaren Nutzen, zum Beispiel eine
dezentralisierte Währung zu sein, die alle auf
der Welt benutzen können, ohne Restriktionen,
egal aus welcher Herkunft, in welchem Land Und
es ist irgendwie eigentlich für für sehr, sehr
reiche Leute auch sogar praktisch in dem
Sinne, dass das sozusagen die müssen keinen
keine LKWs mit Gold mehr transportieren,
sondern können halt innerhalb von wenigen
Sekunden Milliarden von Euros herumschieben
auf der Welt für Centbeträge oder Euro Beträge.
Es kostet dann 3 €, so eine Transaktion
von 50.000.000.000 können. Also das ist
möglich. Kann ich auch noch mal ein
Beispiel verlinken genau so, wenn wir,
wenn wir die Prämisse Bitcoin hatten
nutzen, dann, dann, dann geht es darum,
okay, dann ist ja der Energieverbrauch erst
mal, dass das überhaupt Energie braucht,
erst mal okay, aber dann im zweiten
Schritt könnte man sagen, wie viel.
Und das ist jetzt glaube ich die Diskussion,
über die wir reden. Also sozusagen ist es zu
viel Energie was Bitcoin verbraucht und das ist
total angemessen. Und ich glaube und ich glaube,
da befinden wir uns gerade da zu
evaluieren, wie viel ist es eigentlich.
Dass ein guter Punkt, dass man das immer auch
so ein bisschen erörtern muss angesichts des
Zwecks. Du hast Recht darauf hingewiesen, es gibt
Energie, Vergeudung und es gibt Energie Nutzen,
Nutzung und es gibt Energieverbrauch und
Energie. Vergeudung wollen wir alle nicht.
Der Energieverbrauch muss angemessen
sein am Nutzen und es könnte ja sein.
Das leuchtet mir schon ein, dass Bitcoin
so viele Vorteile hat, dass man sagen kann,
für diese Vorteile muss man ein bisschen
mehr Energie, eben auch ein investieren.
Auf der anderen Seite könnte man auch
sagen, durch die neuere Technologie,
die Grafikkarten und die anderen Mining
Geräte werden immer schneller und Leistung
sparen. Da könnte auch der Energieverbrauch
zurückgehen. Kannst du mal was zum Mining sagen,
was es damit auf sich hat? Man hört
es immer. Mining was ist das? Wieso
muss das gemeint werden? Kann man nicht
Geld prägen oder Geldscheine bedrucken?
Wie wird Bitcoin hergestellt?
Ganz kurz Zuschauer inzwischen.
Auf jeden Fall. Also genau Bitcoin Mining ist
eine Metapher dafür, wie neue Bitcoins erschaffen
werden. Dazu noch mal ein kleiner Basic Fact zu
Bitcoin Es gibt eine einen Supply, also eine Menge
an Bitcoin, die ist fixiert auf 21 Millionen.
Mittlerweile, heute schon heute. Wir haben
19000000/21 innerhalb von 13 Jahren bekommen.
In der Zukunft wird es aber so sein, dass bis
der 21 Millionste Bitcoin geschürft wurde, in
Anführungsstrichen gemeint wurde, vergehen.
Also das passiert dann wahrscheinlich. So haben
Leute berechnet im Jahr 2140 so, das heißt,
da gibt es diese Dynamik, dass das liegt
daran, dass sozusagen die Miner, die. Das
ist eine Metapher dafür, dass man sich bei
der Bestätigung von Transaktionen beteiligt
und dafür eine Belohnung bekommt. Meiner sind
sozusagen die Computer oder Personen hinter
den Computern, die sich am Netzwerk
beteiligen und echte Energie, Strom.
Das, wovon wir hier reden, dafür aufwenden, um
Transaktionen in dieser Blockchain zu bestätigen.
Dezentrale, dezentrale,
das sind dezentrale Verfahren. Jeder kann
Teil dieses Bitcoin Netzwerks werden. Ja.
Genau. Voll wichtiger Punkt.
Ja, und und und. Es ist so,
so alle zehn Minuten im Durchschnitt, das
variiert auch. Aber entsteht ein neuer Block,
und zwar ein Block mit allen Transaktionen,
die in diesem Zeitraum entstanden sind. So,
und damit dieser Block bestätigt werden kann,
ist dieses Blockchain Bitcoin Netzwerk bringt
solche Regeln mit sich, dass sozusagen alle
gleichzeitig versuchen, eine mathematische
Aufgabe zu lösen, was total schwer ist und
viel Arbeit erfordert, Energie erfordert,
um dann als einziger die richtige Lösung
für den aktuellen Block herauszufinden.
Es kann nur einen geben, der diesen neuen Block
herausfindet, diese mathematische Lösung löst
und dann die Bitcoins als Belohnung bekommt.
Das ist dieses Mining und ich will noch ein
paar kurze Aspekte dazu sagen, weil weil
das alles miteinander zusammenhängt. Wenn
wir jetzt so gehen, wir wissen jetzt, Bitcoin
Miner bestätigen Blocks und kriegen dafür eine
Bitcoin als Belohnung. Ich habe vorhin gesagt,
wir sind bei 19 Millionen Bitcoins und es gibt
insgesamt 21 Millionen, aber es dauert
noch total lang, bis alle geschürft sind.
Da fragt man sich, warum. Der Grund dafür
ist, dass die Belohnung für die Mine bei 50
Bitcoins angefangen hat in den 1. vier Jahren und
seitdem alle vier Jahre automatisch durch den Kauf
des Bitcoins die Belohnung für meine halbiert
wird. Mittlerweile sind wir nicht mehr bei 50,
sondern bei 6,125 Bitcoins pro Block Reward
heißt das. Und und daraus ergibt sich halt
verschiedene Sachen, die total wichtig
sind für die Werthaftigkeit von Bitcoin
zum Beispiel kann man davon ausgehen, dass
Bitcoin, die dezentral auf der Welt sind
und sich auch vielleicht gar nicht
kennen, ein Interesse daran haben,
dass diese Transaktionen richtig durchgeführt
werden und dass die auch nicht betrügen?
Also man hat ein Interesse daran, dass diese
Datenbank der Wahrheit entspricht. Warum? Weil
so viel Energie rein gesteckt wurde, so viel
Arbeit so und. Und deswegen heißt das eben
auch Proof of Work Algorithmus der dafür sorgt,
dass durch diese Arbeit, die man reinsteckt,
bewiesen wird, dass man ein Interesse an
der wahrheitsgetreu an diesem Wahrheitswert
der Bitcoin Blockchain hat und da ist dieser
Unglaube, also einer von diesen unglaublich
wertvollen Funktionen und Inhalten der Bitcoin
Blockchain enthalten, weil man sich sozusagen
aus theoretischer Sicht sicher sein kann,
dass die Teilnehmer dieses Netzwerks in gutem
Willen handeln und das ist dann die Begründung
dafür, warum Bitcoin so viel Energie braucht.
Und je mehr Teilnehmer das Netzwerk bekommt,
desto höher wird die Schwierigkeit dieser
mathematischen Aufgabe und desto
mehr Energie muss man reinstecken.
Das heißt, die Energie wird dafür
aufgewendet, diesen STANDARD,
diesen Sicherheitsstandard aufrecht zu halten,
um die Struktur überhaupt dieses Geldes,
die Vertrauensbasis, also die Basis letztendlich
des Geldes, aufrechtzuerhalten und die Basis ist
ja immer verschieden von verschiedenen Geldern,
zum Beispiel Währungen der Euro, Europäische
Zentralbank, die gibt das an und der Unterschied
zum Bitcoin wäre, es gibt da keine zentral Bank,
die irgendwo ein Ort hat, sondern wir alle sind,
wenn wir Teil dieses Blockchain Netzwerks sind.
Die Zentralbank ist eigentlich
eine Zentralbank, könnte man sagen,
keine Zentralbank Und das leuchtet mir sehr
ein, weil ja auch in Zeiten der Digitalisierung
alles vernetzter wird, alles flexibler
wird. Insofern könnte man schon sagen,
Bitcoin ist so ein typisches Beispiel dieser
digitalen Kultur der digitalen Ökonomie,
die da auch entsteht. Ja, Marcel, jetzt bedanke
ich mich vielmals für deine Ausführungen.
Du hast in sehr, sehr viele Interna hier
sehr anschaulich erklärt. Ich glaube, wir
sehen alle, die Bitcoins sind ein interessantes
philosophisches Phänomen. Einerseits virtuelle
Realität sie existieren nicht ausgedruckt
auf scheinen nicht wie Münzen in Metall und
sie haben auch eine tiefere in die Struktur,
die in die Mathematik hineingeht, sie hast du
uns auch erklärt, und es ist eine Vernetzung
und sie sind die wahrscheinlich die Zukunft.
Bitcoin ist ja nicht die einzige Währung,
die es gibt, die einzige Kryptowährung.
Vielleicht kannst du noch ein paar andere
Coins noch mal erwähnen, die es gerade gibt.
Kann ich gerne machen. Also ich würde nur
gerne die Frage noch zu Ende beantworten.
Mit dieser Umwelt Debatte, wenn wir die
zwei Minuten noch verlängern können,
weil genau, sozusagen. Wir waren
ja bei dem Punkt stehengeblieben,
warum warum es jetzt bei Bitcoin der
Energieverbrauch so hoch und wie hoch
ist er eigentlich und kann man was dafür tun,
dass das vielleicht sogar umweltschonend ist?
Es hat so eine Forderung gehabt, dass
Bitcoin vom Aufwand wegkommen sollte
und auf Stufe of Stake wechseln sollte. Das heißt
die Art, wie Bitcoins erzeugt werden und die Art,
wie die Blockchain in Transaktionen bestätigt.
Diese Regel sollte geändert werden. Warum?
Es ist Energie effizienter, verbraucht eben nicht
so viel Energie, weil der Proof wird nicht durch
Arbeit erzeugt, sondern durch die Menge an
Geld, durch den State of money, den man hat.
So, das ist erst mal so eine Forderung auf
Seiten der Umweltschützer. Aber ich glaube,
diese Leute, die das Video gemacht
haben, haben zu wenig in die Mechanismen
und und und und. Konsequenzen und Vorteile
von Bitcoin geschaut und was hier und jetzt
im zweiten Punkt von meinen drei Punkten.
Die Basis für dieses Greenpeace Video zum
Beispiel ist ein akademisches Paper,
was in Nature veröffentlicht wurde.
Und der Grund für diese Hochrechnungen war,
dass zum Beispiel ein Bitcoin so viel Energie
verbraucht wie Schweden, wie ein ganzes
Land so und dann hat sich halt gezeigt,
die Berechnungen, die Art wie das berechnet
wurde ist halt falsch. Selbst im Nature Magazin,
wo dieses Paper veröffentlicht wurde,
wurde es widerlegt von drei neuen Paper,
die danach erschienen sind. Da wurde halt
sozusagen ein bisschen also es ist so was.
Der Punkt ist einfach der Bitcoin verbraucht
viel Energie, aber es verbraucht nicht so viel,
wie in der SZ oder der New York Times oft
steht. Und es gibt verschiedene Arten, wie man
den Energieverbrauch berechnen kann. Da müssen
wir nicht reingehen. Aber ich will nur sagen,
da sollte man einen Blick drauf werfen und sich
überlegen, so stimmt es eigentlich überhaupt.
Und jetzt können wir uns aber
abschließend darauf einigen, okay,
es verbraucht aber viele Energie ist das jetzt
schlecht. Und jetzt gibt es halt so, da könnten
wir ein eigenes Video drüber machen. Diese ganze
Debatte oder dieser Vorschlag, dass man sagt,
Moment einmal, ähm, Bitcoin Mining ist die
einzige Alternative, das einzige System,
was wir haben, was Energieproduktion
unabhängig vom Staat finanziell fördert.
Und dadurch, dass Bitcoin so mining so
aufwendig ist, so teuer, muss man nach
der billigsten Energiequelle schauen. Und
wenn man langfristig denkt, 5 bis 10 Jahre,
dann ist die billigste Energiequelle erneuerbare
Energie. Und erneuerbare Energien sind halt der
Schritt in eine umweltschonende Welt. Und deswegen
ist Bitcoin so vielversprechend bei dem Ziel,
diese Umweltziele zu erreichen, ist das
halt eigentlich total vielversprechend,
weil es auf einmal profitabel ist, sich
Solarzellen aufs Dach zu klatschen.
Und auf einmal kann man statt in 15 Jahren das
Teil in mindestens zehn Jahren abbezahlen. Und
wenn der Kurs steigt, hat man sich schon
nach drei Jahren hin die Kosten und die
Aufwendungen bezahlt und das ist so der
Bogen, den ich spannen wollte zu der Umwelt,
die Verantwortung rauskommt, die man hat zu Ja,
wir sollten, wir sollten die Umwelt schützen.
Wir sollten hier irgendwas machen aber
dann auch zu verstehen, wie können wir
so was wie Bitcoin zu Nutze machen. Hat
das nicht noch mehr Potenzial eigentlich?
Ja, das leuchtet mir sehr ein. Vielen
Dank. Ich habe da so eine Vision,
eine Zukunftsvision wo wir alle schürfen in
Zukunft. Unsere Bitcoins am Rechner haben
dann auf dem Dach Solarzellen und erzeugen dann
praktisch aus alternativen Energien den Strom,
um die Bitcoins zu schürfen. Und
wenn die Sonne fleißig scheint,
was sie ja durch den Klimawandel mehr
tut, können wir mehr Bitcoins schürfen.
Und im Winter deine Wohnung noch heizen.
Und damit kannst du auch noch, weil die so
heiß werden weil sie ja Energie brauchen wird,
kannst du deine Wohnung heizen damit, das ist
auch schon bewiesen. Auch für Quelle hier
rein kann ich auch rein tun und dann kannst
du die Gas Kosten sparen und auch die fossilen
Brennstoffe. Gas kann man auch sich sparen.
Es hat sozusagen diesen unglaublichen.
Das ist also das ist ein realistisches
Potenzial. Ob wir das wirklich erreichen
und ob das wirklich profitabel ist,
das hängt von vielen Faktoren
ab. Aber das Potenzial ist so,
es halt nicht von der Hand zu weisen. Ob es von
Potenz in einen Akt kommt. Das ist halt die.
Die also du hast, glaube jetzt sehr gut
uns gezeigt, wie mit Bitcoin so viele
Dinge miteinander zusammenhängen. Erst mal
wir alle potenziell als Bitcoin schürfen,
dann auch der Energie Aspekt, der dann natürlich
wieder auf alternative Energien verweist und
auch vielleicht auf die Autonomie. Das heißt, wir
müssen nicht nur hinsichtlich des Geldes schauen,
wie wir es verdienen, sondern
auch hinsichtlich die Energie.
Müssen wir vielleicht in Zukunft
noch mehr Verantwortung übernehmen,
auch angesichts dieser Energiekrise, die wir
gerade kriegsbedingt durchleben? Könnte der
Bitcoin eine Art Katalysator sein für ein
Umdenken oder noch ein stärkeres Umdenken
in Richtung alternative Energien, weil wir da
längerfristiger damit dann planen können? Ja,
das leuchtet mir sehr ein. Ich bedanke mich
vielmals für deine Expertise und wir hoffen,
dass die Zuschauerinnen und Zuschauer
viele Anregungen bekommen haben.
Gerne weiterdiskutieren in der Beschreibung
unten unter der Beschreibung im Forum auf
YouTube vielleicht schließen
wir auch mal eine Sendung an,
könnte man einmal mal ein bisschen
dezidierter ein Thema machen, aber
ich finde, wir haben jetzt sehr guten Einblick
bekommen. Also vielen Dank für deine Expertise.
Danke Jörg. Ja, bis vielleicht in der
nächsten Folge und mit mehr Präzision
oder oder auch. Also schauen wir einfach,
was wir noch machen müssen. Und immer.
Alles klar. Tschüss!